everything going wrong for Rudy Giuliani  Giuliani now has been ordered to pay his  ex-wife 225 thousand dollars he's got  two weeks to do it or he's facing jail  time in the meantime Rudy Giuliani is  part of a number of different  investigations including criminal  investigations and you have to wonder  even though Rudy Giuliani was nothing  really to write home about as mayor of  New York City he was generally speaking  beloved nationally after he presided  over New York City during 9 11. he could  have just retired he could have become  like a normal retired Republican and  nobody would have really gone out of  their way to go after him or to hate him  even even though many people don't love  him at the same time and instead Rudy  Giuliani attached his cart to Donald  Trump's horse for lack of a better term  and now it may be years of going from  court to court to court with legal  problems you think he regrets it on some  level